welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
your friendly neighborhood spoiler man
in this video we're breaking down
all the easter eggs hidden details and
things you missed in the eternals
trailer
if you enjoyed the video then i'd be
eternally grateful if you smash the
thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this each and every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the eternals
trailer
okay so shut up for a second yeah just
shut up
are you listening all right well on our
last video yeah we discussed a lot of
plot elements for the movie
including how the eternals themselves
had been created
now what i forgot to preface the video
with is that i was going off plot leaks
for the movie
which had a screening at the start of
the air and a lot of people saying that
i got the origin
story for the eternals wrong but marvel
studios have apparently changed things
up
from how they are in the comics
according to the leaks the deviants were
created by the celestials to hunt
predators their prey on
intelligent life on newly evolving
worlds however they gained a taste for
blood and destruction
and became like a makeup youtuber
starting drama
every single day in a quest to wipe out
life
no matter the cost no one was safe and
thus the celestials created the eternals
to kill the maker sorry that killed the
deviants
now whilst we can't fully verify leaks
like that the viewer apparently supplied
undeniable evidence to the mods at
subreddit marvel studios spoilers
so they do seem pretty legit now i will
be talking about some of those leaks in
this video but
nothing that i think will completely
ruin the film this is mainly going to be
going over the context
and setup of certain shots so you have
more of an idea of what's happening in
the trailer
now the origins for the eternals and
deviants is apparently explained in the
opening title card for the film
and from there we jump to mesopotamia to
see the deviants attacking people on
earth
the eternals show up and save the day
which several of the shots in this
trailer likely showcase
there was also a mention of the heroes
lining up in a triangular pose before we
cut to the marvel studios logo
which did seem to happen in the first
teaser the leak said that the film
actually begins in the past and they
discussed how we kickstart the movie
with a father and his son going fishing
they are then attacked by the deviants
which is when the eternals show up
and reveal themselves they save the day
and end up working with early man to
help them develop their technologies
and advance as a civilization cersei and
icarus are in a relationship that lasts
for centuries
but they grow further and further apart
and she ends up dating dane whitman
who is played by kit harrington dane
goes on to become the black knight
but whether he's in the film as a
character or if it's just teased
remains to be seen we get flashes of
cersei and icarus at the dawn of
civilization
then jump to what i believe is india
where they look happy and then cut to
the desert where they look pretty upset
i'm guessing that they break about this
point and this opens the door for her to
go and date dane
now the teaser trailer doesn't really
give too much away
and i can imagine that the majority of
this is set in the opening 20
minutes of the movie rather than coming
out with bombastic moments and giving
away much of the plot
it's very much showing how they've
watched and helped humanity to grow and
develop
the eternals have walked amongst us for
millennia rather than being people who
participated in our
actions when the first teaser dropped
there were a lot of people wondering why
they never showed up to help out in
infinity war
and i think this new look very much
teases that they are onlookers
rather than people that are active
participants to me the mcu eternals are
very much people that will build the
tool and show you how to use it
rather than outright telling you like
comment subscribe which you should do
now fastos can be seen in the teaser
actually creating a device
and he is very much the inventor of the
group in the leaks it said that he's had
his hand in multiple inventions that
have propelled humanity forward
i love how we very much get this idea
from this shot i also love how sprite is
just sitting around there too
and that kind of hammers home that the
eternals are very much watchers
so here just lazing around yeah great
little easter egg
and there's also what i believe is
thinner putting her hand into dirt
in order to help water spring from it so
that plants and crops can grow
you may notice that their powers are
golden and this is because they pull
from cosmic abilities
which were of course set up in captain
marvel as we learned in one division
red represents chaos magic purple is
dark magic
and orange is very much a typical
standard magic so like that they're very
much keeping things uniformed thinner
can also be seen training
and she is very much a warrior that's
linked in with zeus
and ancient greece we can also catch a
grand city
likely mesopotamia which they stand in
front of
and the more ancient structures around
them kind of show how the rest of
humanity was doing
there was a time when egypt was very
much the hub for civilization
whilst europe was still vastly behind
and i like how this hints to humanity's
development
at the hands of the eternals there's
very much this idea of the ancient world
and them living through the centuries
which is hinted at by makari flicking
through a book at super speed
in this room we can catch an ankh which
is a symbol that represents life in
ancient egypt
a medieval knight and several other
artifacts from over the centuries
is that a ps4 i don't know anyway this
shows how long they've been looking over
history
since coming to earth in order to stop
the deviants the eternals apparently
killed the deviants
or at least they thought they did in the
present day we learned that they've
actually made an apology video
and are now back in full effect they
apparently attack cersei early on in the
movie
and during the battle we learn that this
new kind of deviant has the ability to
heal
this starts off a mystery in which they
must get to the bottom of exactly what's
going on
and they travel to ajac apparently after
the eternals defeated the deviants
they decided that it was time to take a
break and decided to go their own
separate ways
in the trailer we caught ajac in the
desert i think that she will probably be
on her own at this point
living a low-key life far removed from
the wars that she was once a part of
now the rest of the eternals are also in
their own places
spread across the planet cersei is in
the uk working as a teacher
and this is how she meets dane dina and
gilgamesh are apparently in australia
and the latter is meant to be in love
with the former but it's unrequited
fastos is going to be the first gay
superhero in the mcu
and he will be living with his husband
and their kid makari is still living on
the eternal ship
and apparently there's an endless food
source there so you know what just she's
just decided to chill
now kingo is a bollywood superstar actor
and according to the leaks he travels
with someone who documents everything
about his life
this is why in the teaser we saw him
stood next to someone with the camera
and cameras could also be seen when the
group were at the village a lot of
people thought that this was a mistake
and that the camera crew had been caught
in the shot but i think they're probably
just part of kingo's group
now at the village is apparently where
drug is the character has the ability to
control people's minds
and he has been doing it to the locals
there to see if he can manipulate people
on a grand scale
this is why there's people standing
around all wearing the same things
and he's pretty much a cult leader at
this point he wants to do this in order
to see if there's a way to stop war
and he's lost faith that humanity will
ever be able to live peacefully
we do see them raise their guns at one
point so perhaps they will always resort
to this
or it could just be the character using
them as a way to guard the area
we end with them in the present
discussing iron man and captain rogers
being gone
and they then suggest who could lead the
avengers icarus puts himself forward
but he's laughed out the room probably
because they're going to make it bray
larson
you sucker i'm just kidding
also notice how sprite calls him captain
rogers and not captain america
and this is clearly acknowledging that
sam has taken on the mantle
now as for my reaction to the trailer i
think the first proper teaser brings up
with it that's gonna have fans excited
but also leave some general audiences a
bit cautious
these characters they're they're a bit
weird aren't they bit weird
and every time marvel adapts a
cosmic-based comic i think it's quite
risky
i feel like this is why they've made
sure to get the best people for the job
and with chloe xiao coming off an oscar
win for best director
i do think that the movie is in safe
hands the cast is also
very established and all of them have
been in something that's regarded as a
classic
or it was until season 8 but we'll not
get into that now the characters are
quite unique
and though they're not really classed as
being some of the big names at marvel
i think this movie will probably get a
lot of interest in it
marvel never really dropped the ball and
this trailer has got me more excited for
the film
than i actually thought that it would
there's even rumors that marvel are
pushing the movie to be shown early at
festivals
so they must be quite confident in its
quality as this is the studio that
killed and cloned tom holland
because he spoiled things however they
are potentially dropping it very early
for critics
as the director at cairns has teased
that a planetary blockbuster
will be shown at the festival this could
really be anything but with zhao's
accolades
they probably would want to secure her
next project anyway
really really well made by the looks of
it i think it's going to open the door
for a lot of things in the mcu
great first full trailer and i enjoyed
it and i hope you enjoyed the video too
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it
and what you want to see in the movie
also if there's anything we missed which
i'm sure there is
then make sure you comment below and let
me know as to thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize throughout the end of the month in
which we're giving away three copies of
the box set on
screen right now all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the trailer
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now serve that to
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the first teaser
which goes over the characters and their
powers we kind of clear up all the
questions around them and i didn't just
want to be repeating myself
so definitely go and check that out if
you want to know more about the core
cast
without the way thank you for sitting
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace